it's easy to forget that last night 1
billion people went to sleep without
access to electricity 1 billion people
two and a half billion people did not
have access to clean cooking fuels or
clean heating fuels those are the
problems in the developing world and
it's easy for us not to be empathetic
with those people who seem so distance
from us but even in our own world the
developed world we see the tension of
stagnant economies impacting the lives
of people around us we see it in whole
pieces of the economy where the people
involved have lost hope about the future
and despair about the present we see
that in the brexit vote we see that in
the Sanders Trump campaigns in my own
country but even in countries as
recently turning the corner towards
being in the developed world in China we
see the difficulty that President Xi has
as he begins to unemploy so many people
in his coal and mining industries who
see no future for themselves as we as a
society figure out how to manage the
problems of the developed world and the
problems of the developing world we have
to look at how we move forward and
manage the environmental impact of those
decisions we've been working on this
problem for 25 years since Rio the Kyoto
Protocol's our most recent move is the
Paris tree and the resulting climate
agreements that are being ratified by
nations around the world I think we can
be very hopeful that those agreements
which are bottom-up agreements where
nations have said what they think they
can do are genuine and forthcoming for
the vast majority of the parties the
unfortunate thing is that now as we look
at the independent analyses of what
those climate treaties are liable to
yield
the magnitude of the problem before us
becomes clear this is the United States
Energy Information agency's assessment
of what will happen if the countries
implement the climate commitments that
they've made in Paris between now and
2040 it shows basically co2 emissions
around the world over the next thirty
years there are three things that you
need to look at and appreciate one co2
emissions are expected to continue to
grow for the next 30 years in order to
control climate co2 emissions have to
literally go to zero because it's the
cumulative emissions that drive heating
on the planet this should tell you that
we are losing the race to fossil fuels
the second thing you should notice is
that the bulk of the growth comes from
the developing countries from China from
India for the rest of the world which
includes South Africa and Indonesia in
Brazil as most of these countries move
their people into the lower range of
lifestyles that we literally take for
granted in the developed world the final
thing that you should notice is that
each year about 10 Giga tons of carbon
are getting added to the planet's
atmosphere and then diffusing into the
ocean into the land that's on top of the
550 Giga tons that are in place today at
the end of 30 years we will have put 850
Giga tons of carbon into the air and
that probably goes a long way towards
locking in a 2 to 4 degrees C increase
in global mean surface temperatures
locking in ocean acidification and
locking in sea level rise now this is a
projection made by men by the actions of
society and it's ours to change not to
accept but the magnitude of the problem
is
something we need to appreciate
different nations make different energy
choices it's a function of their natural
resources it's a function of their
climate it's a function of the
development paths that they've followed
as a society it's a function of where on
the surface of the planet they are are
they where it's dark a lot of the time
or are they at the mid-latitudes
many many many things go into the
choices of countries and they each make
a different choice the overwhelming
thing that we need to appreciate is the
choice that China has made China has
made the choice and will make the choice
to run on coal the United States has an
alternative it can run on natural gas as
a result of the inventions of fracking
and shale gas which we have here they
provide an alternative the OECD Europe
has a choice
it has renewables that it can afford to
deploy in Germany because it's rich
enough to afford to do it the French and
the British show interest in nuclear
power Eastern Europe still very heavily
committed to natural gas and coal and
with natural gas that comes from Russia
with all of its entanglements China has
many fewer choices and a much harder
road to hoe
if you look at China and you ask
yourself why has coal been so important
to it you have to remember what China's
done China brought people to power not
power to people it didn't do rural
electrification it urbanized it
urbanized by taking low-cost labor and
low-cost energy creating export
industries that could fund a tremendous
amount of growth if we look at China's
path all of us know that prosperity in
China has dramatically increased in 1980
eighty percent of China's population
live below the extreme poverty level
below the level of having a dollar in
ninety cents per person per day by the
year 2000 only 20%
of China's population lived below the
extreme poverty level a remarkable feat
admittedly with some costs and civil
liberties that would be tough to accept
in the Western world but the impact of
all that wealth allowed people to get
massively better nutrition it allowed
water pipes to be placed it allowed
sewage pipes to be placed dramatic
decrease in diarrheal diseases at the
cost of some outdoor air pollution but
in 1980 and even today the number one
killer in China is indoor air pollution
because people do not have access to
clean cooking and heating fuels in fact
in 2040 it's still estimated that 200
million people in China will not have
access to clean cooking fuels they have
a remarkable path to follow India also
needs to meet the needs of its own
people and it's going to do that by
burning coal when we look at the EIA s
projections of coal burning in India
India will supply nearly four times as
much of its energy from coal as it will
from renewables it's not because they
don't know the alternatives it's because
rich countries can do what they choose
poor countries do what they must so what
can we do to stop coals emissions in
time what can we do that changes this
forecast that's in front of us because
it's a forecast that we can change if we
have the will to do it first of all we
have to think about the magnitude of the
problem between now and twenty forty
eight hundred to sixteen hundred new
coal plants are going to be built around
the world this week between one and
three one gigawatt coal plants are being
turned on around the world
that's happening regardless of what we
want because the people that rule their
countries assessing the interests of
their citizens have decided it's in
their interest of their citizens to do
that and that's going to happen unless
they have a better alternative and every
100 of those plants will use up between
1% and 3% of the Earth's climate budget
so every day that you go home thinking
you should do something about global
warming at the end of that week remember
somebody fired up a coal plant that's
going to run for 50 years and take away
your ability to change it what we've
forgotten is something that Vinod Khosla
used to talk about a man of Indian
ethnicity but an American venture
capitalist and he said back in the early
2000s that if you needed to get China
and India off of fossil fuels you had to
create a technology that passed the
Chindia test Chindia being the appending
of the two words it had to be first of
all viable meaning that technically they
could implement it in their country and
that it would be accepted by the people
in the country - it had to be a
technology that was scaleable that it
could deliver the same benefits on the
same timetable as fossil fuels so that
they can enjoy the kind of life again
that we take for granted in third it had
to be cost effective without subsidy or
without mandate it had to stand on its
own two feet it could not be maintained
for that many people if in fact those
countries had to go begging or had some
foreign country say I won't trade with
you in order to get the technology shift
to occur if you look at the Chindia test
we simply have not come up with
alternatives that meet that test that's
what the EIA forecast tells us China's
building 800 gigawatts of coal
400 gigawatts of hydro about 200
gigawatts of nuclear and on an energy
equivalent basis adjusting for
intermittency about a hundred gigawatts
of renewables 800 gigawatts of cold
they're doing that knowing the costs
better than any other country knowing
the need better than any other country
but that's what they're aiming for in
2040 unless we give them a better choice
to give them a better choice it's going
to have to meet the Chindia test if you
look at all the alternatives that are up
there they're really two that come near
to meeting first is this area of new
nuclear that I'll talk about in just a
second it's a new generation of nuclear
plants that are on the drawing boards
around the world and the people who are
developing these say we can get them in
position to demo by 2025 and to scale by
2030 if you will just let us the second
alternative that could be there in time
is utility-scale solar backed up with
natural gas which we can use today
versus the batteries which are still
under development so what's holding new
nuclear back outdated regulations and
yesterday's mindsets we have not used
our latest scientific thinking on
radiological health to think how we
communicate with the public and govern
the testing of new nuclear reactors we
have new scientific knowledge that we
need to use in order to improve the way
we regulate nuclear industry the second
thing is we've got a mindset that it
takes 25 years and 2 to 5 billion
dollars to develop a nuclear power plant
that comes from the historical military
mindset of the places that nuclear power
came from these new nuclear ventures are
saying that they can deliver power for 5
cents a kilowatt hour they can deliver
it for 100 gigawatts a year they can
demo it by 2025 and they can deliver it
in scale by 2030 if only we give them a
chance right now we're basically waiting
for a miracle
what we need is a choice if they can't
make it safe if they can't make it cheap
it should not be deployed but what I
want you to do is not carry an idea
forward but write your leaders right the
head of the NGOs you support and tell
them to give you the choice not the best
thank you very much